you grew up there as well and comes
Ridley Greg walks ready to shoot scores
Greg Fires at home to give Ottawa the lead as
he snaps it over the shoulder of Jerry that
seemed like a harmless play but I love that
set breakout here by the Sands that created
a lot of speed through the neutral zone and Randy
Greg shooting in stride is able to curl and drag
this and fire at High glove craze walks in winds
and fires that's blocked lifted up by Giroux he
finds total on the break in comes Tim stutzler
stop by Jerry rebound could chuck scores pretty
good Chuck slides it by Derry and Ottawa takes a
two-nothing lead [Applause] and could chuck we're
back to work and what could have been Ryan Graves
had a lot of time and he steps right into a shot
that gets blocked in front it hits a leg [Music]
and Ottawa after the races and it stuck to it with
speed kuchuk runs a little bit of interference but
he does a good job getting to the front of the net
and Trina Crosby's banana bread his
mom is not about his legendary Jake
Sanderson works it in shoot Terry makes
the save on that and Sid apparently is
quite Adept at it as well plays that
back up picked off by Brady good job
walks in and fires he ripped that wide to
check on the rebound hamburger one as well
good job who's behind the goal he's worked that
free on Pederson and the Chuck keeps banging away
down there great from the start of the second
picks this Puck off just goes over them the
top of the net but watch him work on the boards
here uses his physicality doesn't turn away from
pucks two guys and he's heavy on the puck this is
what bradykuchak does so well along with Sydney
back in 2003. look out doing here Joseph fell to
[__] loose in front dread gets it across that
backhand shot stopped by Jerry you know what I
like about Ottawa so far is they're pressuring
the puck Pittsburgh back on their heels a little
bit here and early in the second period back for
Carlson's shoes that was blocked by Matthew
Joseph an umbrella by struts the short hand
and he's got Joseph with him in comes Ed Carlson
broke it up and the puck winds up right in his
feet along with Greg Here Comes Thomas Shabbat
holds weights and shoots Jerry makes the Stop
and swaps away the rebound Crosby feeds that
back to Graves rips it and shoots took right
on and Corpus Ella makes the stop the tang in for
Raquel sweeps that down to Crosby he and Shabbat
collided Crosby throws that back in front of
her giving Shabbat the Heisman there there's
the initial redirect good save by corpusalo block
another one that's two yeah that took a fight out
of here Olivia Joseph charging with it shoots
and knocked Away by jarring Eller punch there by
Matthew Joseph you know Sharkey wrap around trying
knocked Away by jarion sent back down the ice
as Shabbat hustles back for Pittsburgh past the
Midway corner to second period still two nothing
Ottawa and baffison with the steal works in great
move like shoots point blank on a save made by
jari those are dangerous bounces and this what
a takeaway here by Drake Batterson head up the
hallway it's not like the old Buffalo Auditorium
where they had the Zamboni guy helping out with
the foot yeah Houston just press his foot on a
door behind the bench good one-timer and a Rolling
Puck he tries to go through his legs Shabbat got
back but Raquel steps into him picked up by Crosby
Sanders it Carlson shoots hit the goal post the
turnover Raquel strong on the puck Crosby through
the seam yeah corpusalo gets it with his blocker
and it hits rust and goes right through batted
Down by Crosby rolls towards the goal picked up by
Shabbat who just left that trickle down to Corpus
plays that back to Carlson for Pederson shoots
knocked down by corpusalem up ahead to Raquel
and Ricardo Kell drops it back to Malkin feeds
across from runs he couldn't grab a Rolling
Puck and corporado's got him [Applause] Crosby
down to Raquel for Crosby [Applause] sign of the
goal that was blocked by Sanderson
and Raquel put the rebound why
not bad to Eller bars Heller winds in shoots
and purposely got a quick piece of that
real quality stats last year people by
Riley Smith drop some knocking back in
front I want to stop there by purpose
still loose down it was chicory to knock
it down because it's a three-on-2 situation
shabbat's gonna get caught outside the dots
and right on the back door corpusala with the
redirect zahorna gets the opportunity tries to
elevate it corporcella with the good read doesn't
over push in comes Shabbat flies out across and
benefits him with a hard shot Jerry got the arm
on that before Casella swaps that away and here
is Crosby being tied up by Shabbat Crosby works
it back throws it in front of that buck tripled
over to lead pass for Tara single busting you
with Giroux parasinkle shoots Charlie to save
rebound loose in front and Carl's arrange
back to take that away from Khloe Giroud
Bear by Chuck with a big hit by
Britney Kentucky comes the horn
a shoot second chance and columbusella
makes it that rebound back in front of
purpose out a great City there as
he took that away from Riley Smith
[Applause]
makes a save on that Crosby park in front
of the goal here's Carlson four Raquel
down the Crosby little backhand shot
stopped by corpusalo in tight there's
gonna be a conversation a couple
things that have happened tonight
for the Penguins Pittsburgh's gotta be find a way
on this power play to be a lot more lethal Raquel
moves in to the tank Carlson steps around Sterling
shoots and Corpus Sullivan's glove on that
Joseph back for rust walks in slaps it down
step in the high sloppers throws him that
Butters down and he's bumped down by Siobhan
the punch still loose Smith poking at it and
the puckers into the glove here Joseph back
to rust see in the corner for Smith trying to
Center bounce off the Stick Of Zoo break down
to corpuscello and he's able to hang on Riley
Smith wants it because he's got an option
there Jeff Carter on the back post you get
that puck through that's a wide open net near
Olivier Joseph back for hinostrosa feeds that
down Connor gets a stick on that a trickles
down and corporalo able to hang on that's a
sneaky little touch play there times a goaltender
will think that Carter's gonna grab this Puck and
try and force feed it instead he just rolls
it up to Center Ice picked up like a Chuck
and the puck did not cross the line kept Alive
by Carlson now picked up by shirt Jay and he
backs it back out of the Pittsburgh Zone stood
for racing after Malkin gets there and scores
but it's Tim sterzler that speed moving
gets inside position strong on his stick
Gino Malkin was at the end of a shift and
didn't have much left in the tank legs were
a bit heavy and it's stutzler that just slides
it into the empty net time winds down here well
they came to see Sydney Crosby and they saw
ottawa's young guys go to work Final Shots
40-24 corpusalem a full game shutout and Ottawa
wins it by a final score of three to nothing